thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
look at that graphic welcome back to the
break room everybody our our daily uh
show that keeps you updated on all the
nerdy news you need to know and today
that nerdy news is about the Barbie okay
we got a teacher
we've got to kill the Barbie uh we are
going to be getting uh Brandon and
Jessica prepared a an impromptu but
thorough live breakdown that they're
going to be doing of the Barbie teaser
trailer that came out earlier today also
on this episode we're going to talk this
new Henry Cavill news he's moving on
from Superman to a new franchise Peyton
Reed uh is done uh making small movies
for Marvel that's right it's going big
um and we give some of our best of the
Year picks uh with me to do that and
more we've got uh from my left to my
right Brandon Barracks here hey Cory
Jean dro's here
Hector's here welcome back Hector yeah
and Jessica yeah look at that all the
points of articulation Jessica's here
but
um please let's jump right into uh the
topic of the day I didn't notice that
our names had logos
nice work Purdue
produce episodes
there's also our Stranger Things episode
um the first teaser trailer is here it
dropped this morning and we all freaked
out about it not as much as koi did who
um who invaded our slack I didn't know
it was on our slack Channel and he
invaded it I talked so much
cryptococcion I was like when he posted
last night I was like oh my God that's
that's the secret I'm always watching
I'm like waiting and then like my
Barbie's too big a deal and
um so we're all very excited and I know
you guys are probably watch it a hundred
times but you're gonna watch it 101
times because we're going to talk about
it right now let's play the trailer
since the beginning of time
since the first little girl ever existed
there have been dolls
but the dolls were always and forever
baby dolls
until
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh my gosh
sweet sweet incredible incredible I'm so
happy they were able to squeeze
everybody that was announced to be in
the movie almost everyone but the main I
think the core the core like six that's
right uh we opened the trailer with
these poor little girls that you saw at
the beginning um I was probably one of
them
um where they weren't able to play with
any like women Dolls yet it's just all
baby dolls and I know that feeling
because I had a baby born
um this opening is also like a play off
of the 2001 Space Odyssey clearly the
dawn of man entrance yeah look at that
same version yeah producer John put
these together they're incredible how
good Greta Gerwig did on like
replicating these shots uh and really
matching them the little shoes yeah wow
so many great Illusions this scene the
dawn of man obviously 2001 is Space
Odyssey uh
I mean that wasn't iconic just like so
good Obelisk yeah the touchy you're
being scared of it I love it
oh my gosh I love this so good so good I
want to see when she throws the baby
because yeah yeah
I want to watch 2001 again this is great
I know we'll remember when it Winks at
you in 2001 yeah
we're done with it
the voice over this was Helen Mirren who
had not previously been attached to this
film I don't know if she's in it I hope
not I hope none of that opening is in
the film I think yeah I hope that was
just for the trailer uh mirin has been
doing the voice uh the voiceover on the
show documentary now which parodies
famous documentaries and she seems to be
continuing that Trend with this
stylistic take on 2001 Space Odyssey uh
such a good opening really loved it
really loved it yeah the if you guys
didn't get your eardrums blasted oh
sorry
what the heck
like a figure of speech doesn't think
people say sorry so sorry boy uh the
opening is coming by the loud
instrumentals of also sprock uh Zara
zeustras uh by Richard Strauss also used
in the 2001 Space Odyssey you've seen a
different play on of it people make fun
of it all the time in animation uh
Barbie is also sporting her classic
first outfit launched by Mattel in 1959
this is the first outfit that Barbie was
ever put in and this outfit shaped
history this outfit this this look
everything shaped history the font
introduces director Gary's name and the
Barbie title in the same classic Barbie
font over the history the Barbie font
has changed clearly but this looks
closer to the 1975 to the 1991 style
that was used
it's so interesting research yeah I love
that wait pull that up again I just like
looking at the evolution I'm a big fan
very close to the original one I love
that I like
but yeah it's so funny because that that
70s fun that because it went again it
went from 19 to what 1991 is that what
it said that's the one that I think of
when I think about Barbie it's funny
because I go to the 2004 one with the
little signal oh
talking about the font and everyone's
probably like we don't care move on but
look pull that up again because I don't
like I don't like the one with the
flower it only lasted a year look at
that yeah
I love them I always love Barbie that's
why I'm dressed like this do you have a
favorite which one's your most surprised
possession I actually have the 2000
remember do you remember at a time where
there were the collectible Barbies that
were made for each year yes
um I have the 2 000 Millennium Barbie
still pull up that figure
it's perfect not ready we still wrapped
I have never opened it since I got it in
99 and well I'm obsessed with it that is
dedication I collected each one up until
2009. we were talking right before air I
think it'd be a great idea for things
that are this like self-aware to do
trailers that are in reference to other
properties and show like 10 seconds of
foot yeah I love that this gave us a
tone by way of not telling us a thing
about the movie because it knows that
it's going to be Preposterous and all
the people talking about it have made it
like this is going to change the world
so they just doesn't want a space on you
that's genius and then they give us just
enough just a little C move just a
little baby goose
just you wait they're gonna they're
gonna go into those little tastes
um and director Greta gerwood was born
in 83 so this Barbie font she would have
seen in the most in her Peak play years
that was her fun dog uh Barbie was of
course written by Greta gerwick and Noah
bombach we've been together for 11 years
in real life and even have a child
together maybe that plays with Barbie
who knows Gerwig had most recently
directed Little Women in lady bird
bombach of course is a writer director
himself having most recently done
marriage story The Myra Witt stories and
Francis ha which also great a girl with
his Angel wrote that together the film
stars Margot Roby uh Ryan Gosling simulu
Issa Ray Kate McKinnon America Ferreira
and Hari Naf and uh Will Ferrell well
there's more well yeah we'll get into it
perhaps most intriguing sex education's
Emma Mackie also signed on to appear
alongside uh some of her Netflix
co-stars with rumors that she's playing
like a Margot Robbie doppelganger and
could be playing one of Barbie's three
younger sisters
because she looks Justice she does and
she doesn't I think out of everyone
brunette no there's another one way yeah
ready or not
we don't know much about the film but we
have heard that it's going to center
around a doll Barbie living in Barbie
land who's forced to leave due to her
so-called imperfections I don't know how
you found him on Marco my guy uh she
sets off an adventure in the real world
and is discovering along the way that
Perfection can only be their True
Perfection can only be found within uh
let's keep going through this trailer uh
so after that incredible opening we cut
to Barbie's Dreamland and let me tell
you this place it's nice it's insane all
right there's a lot here we got a pink
Ferris wheel of course you see that
there we have a pink Statue of Liberty
uh we have the pink Capitol Building uh
right there all the homes here that
resemble our Malibu Barbie's dream house
over the years the multiple open floor
levels uh there's like a little twisty
elevator you can see on one uh some of
them have slides also so it's like very
cool that they kept that aesthetic they
like the little elevator right there I
had that and I couldn't find the image
from mine
but it's one where you like you push you
pull up or you wheel up and she just
turns as she comes up It's So Glamorous
of that one in like
2006.00 yeah
also in the this Dreamland there's uh
Chelsea's tree house uh right there that
and that was like an actual toy that is
like the exact one Chelsea's one of the
younger sisters yeah yeah she doesn't
get a dream home she gets a tree house
sorry sorry Chelsea uh there's also a
pink Lighthouse there in the back uh
there's an American flag with pink and
pastel colors now this Jessica found I
think this is a great so the airport
there is designed after LAX but right
behind that palm tree it's b-a-x instead
of LAX I would assume for Barbie uh also
we think this is in California because
there's mountains on the side and
there's like a Randy's donut yeah
definitely a donut shop that you saw in
like Iron Man into the big donut on top
this is like very outlay so this is
maybe taking place in a Los Angeles I
mean it is a Malibu b-a-x because the a
in LAX stands for Angeles so is it gonna
be Barbie Angela's internet he's a
Barbie angel baby maybe it is
that's very funny also the pictures that
we all got so excited about when BBW was
founded were filmed in Venice California
yeah BBW in this context very important
break room Barbie watch okay
that's why I was saying it before we've
been down for the Barbie system
also in the in the Dreamland off to the
side there on the left side of the frame
there's a bowling sign there's like a w
and an L we can see and it really keeps
the aesthetic of 50s bowling Barbie uh
which was released uh at some point
there uh we're gonna see all sorts of
variations of Mario sure and of course
the pink Corvette is driving around in
the Dreamland you gotta have a pink
Corvette when it comes to Barbie
literally did a lot of studying so much
so that I went and also studied and was
like hmm good job yeah so we cut to what
could be the sporty cans that's Ryan
Gosling shooty gotwa and Kinsley Ben
adir he's wearing what could be their
Harley-Davidson outfit for Ken
um it's like metal it's like his little
waist thing
it says
the men around them are fighting and
willing different sporty instruments
electrostic uh we got tennis racket we
got a jug pin far left I think that's a
shovel uh it looks like they're battling
on paddle boats there's also like a fake
horse right behind I don't think you can
see it in this shot but there's a little
more curl of his hair there it's a big
horse on a stick like an old school one
um which could uh also be on the paddle
boat wait yeah some of them are like
paddle boats on the side and the one
behind it might be a horse instead of a
swan paddle boat like a horse now do you
think this is like it was all the sporty
cans doing something and then [ __ ] hit
the fans kind of like and they had I'm
thinking of the Anchorman fight scene
right maybe it's something like that I'm
still convinced that it's a dance
sequence uh I don't know if this is
fully a musical yet but like Barbie is a
partier and Barbie goes to clubs and how
are you gonna have a Barbie movie
without so much dancing which we see in
the trailer a lot of so I I also here's
another uh guest too you guys were
describing I had not heard this
wonderful description of the plot that
Barbie finds an imperfection and then
has to leave kicked out of Barbie land
it feels very much like elf right which
I love yeah
and sorry if you guys are going to
mention this but um producer John is
keeps mentioning that like this movie
has been described as
um 2001 meets Truman Show okay
um there's a little bit of like
realizing that you're not living in the
actual real world so maybe with Barbie
finding the imperfection and she's
getting kicked out or something it's
almost kind of like you know how like in
the Zoolander movie yeah Derek has his
homies that they're just like in that
world but like Derek is the one that
sometimes like has to like question you
know he's like what if what if we're
more than this or whatever what if some
something happens that maybe it is like
they're just sporting guys but something
kind of breaks their brain and that's
what causes spider thing
is either it comes out of the case
either Barbies or something that could
that could make it so that it could
because everything you guys said I'm
like this movie looks so insane it could
be at all it could be them just doing
sports it could be a musical number it
could be a fight sequence I have no idea
but I can't wait to see it I hope it's
Barbie realizing she needs to go versus
her getting kicked out correct yeah yeah
because it seems like she's gonna be
kicked out
also uh if we go back to that shot of
all those Ken's yeah if you make a Ken
movie without these short shorts then
it's not an actual sporty Ken sporty can
rep short shorts till the day which is
never uh there's this is my favorite
Kindle because it's Ken that you can
shave
yeah I think so I think it's like a
hurricane
yeah um yeah but you can shave them but
I just love the outfit that they put
they didn't need to put them in that
album
we're next introduced to Issa Ray's
Barbie uh she has a sash it says
president and all the women are wearing
matching pink jumpsuits behind her and
I've never wanted to belong in a group
this is probably inside that pink
Capitol building that we saw earlier the
pink giant marbled columns oops sorry oh
that yep yep no yeah there you go it's
probably the pink Capitol building in
the back by Statue of Liberty it also
has giant marbled pink columns so it's
probably just like a judgey place a
horse I wonder if it's the horse
continuity so we were talking about this
earlier the horse uh genuinely kind of
as a joke horses are very important
because what's next to a Barbie girl's
uh a horse girl
and Barbie has a series of different
horses throughout the years
one's named Tawny
um I think she had a spirit she had oh
my gosh what other ones does she have
because Chelsea had a
I'm trying to remember it because in the
they really kept it to her earlier years
because clearly at the beginning of
Barbie stages they were like every
girl's a horse girl now they're like no
that's not true um but also like uh
Brandon said before we started shooting
you know how like in the Capitol
Building they'll have pictures of like
an eagles
yeah that's actually great yeah yeah and
also Easter Ray must be the most
important person because she has a pink
owl while everyone there behind them are
uh Brown there's a brown one back there
she's got a pink one you can't see it
right now also like on the Deus there
there's those little microphones but
they're pink so yeah this does seem like
a government body of some time no I see
I see I see yeah the great uh Barbie
government I am so impressed with all of
the work you guys put into this this is
incredible at least this is amazing I
love Barbie
to are very unstable come on this show
come on the show oh my gosh
we think he's like dancing Ken which was
like a variation of Ken now he said his
in he has said in interviews how he
started taking dance lessons again since
being cast in the Barbie movie so it's
safe to assume that cam will never stop
doing this is real quick this is he
looks he's very Gene Kelly right yeah
he's shot right like and that is
um you know An American in Paris or
Umbrellas of sherberg there was like
this period in like 1950s musicals where
they loved those like primary colors and
the like high contrast
the Greaser one right and when I say
Greece run he's not wearing a leather
jacket but it's still like the Aubrey's
lightning when they're working on a
black shirt yeah yeah I mean the pink
socks you gotta love them great look I
also I want this to be like in the
Barbie Dreamland they won't stop dancing
and then that's when Margot Robbie's
like why are we dancing
the final shout out of the trailer is
somewhere in Dreamland we think because
the there's these matching pink
lampposts that Lamppost you see behind
her you can see in the earlier shot plus
these look like the dream houses they
were like in the houses yeah yeah the
the no walls the like multi-floor stuff
like this is probably the street that
she lives on we're an evening wear uh I
I see this is like the opening number of
the movie right like introducing all the
characters that's Barbie is this movie
gonna be a full-on musical I hope it
should be but it should have a couple
dances I think the beginning will be and
then when they leave Barbie Dream Land
and go to just normal there's no more
she's gonna try dancing and someone's
like shut up uh there's so much BTS
stuff that came out remember the leaked
photos and all that stuff and there was
footage of her stealing her cowboy pink
outfit when she exits one of the stores
on Venice so she's clearly just going
through the world as a Barbie not
realizing the real world yeah
um so it's gonna be like Brady Bunch
like she leaves Barbie Landing comes
with it yeah
I'm into it Amen to it thank you thank
you so uh Will Ferrell is cast in and he
did say I get to play the CEO of Mattel
and be the guy who's just insensitive
but weird and then not to spoil anything
but anyways that's what's exciting he
plays the CEO of tell Mattel exists in
this universe right so I do think they
get buzz lightyeared and break out of
their cages yeah
I'm not scared yeah I think I think it's
more of a koi you'll understand this
that Barbie land is another dimension
sure that is so powerful that it is able
to subconsciously influence the doll
makers of our world to create dolls in
the images of the people who live in
Barbie land does that make sense yeah
but somehow Barbie Margot Robbie is able
to punch through to the real world right
but she's still in her it's almost like
the season finale series finale of
Spider-Man the Animated Series by what
happened in Spider-Man the Animated
Series
and Spider-Man was like thanks for
creating me and it was like the other
spider versus because he's free so
that's what's going to happen
Will Ferrell's gonna be like Stan Lee of
this universe well we've only talked
about another uh The Lego Movie yeah
yeah featured Will Ferrell in a framing
device right we're playing with the
Legos with his son or whatever right
like is there some potential there but
then that would not explain why Ken and
Barbie end up breaking out in there
we saw that behind the scenes footage of
Will Ferrell chasing them on the roller
skates with his like gang of also roller
skating suited man yeah so I think he's
just trying to get her to go back into
the world and she refuses also just to
know uh Ryan uh Gosling said Ken's got
no money he's got no job and he's got no
car and I don't know what the rest says
and he's got no car uh he's got no house
he's going through some stuff so he's
probably just following Barbie maybe
that's why his dress like biker can
because he's like I don't have any
clothes
yeah or is that him breaking back in I
also hear Johnny like he might be like
William zapka and Cobra cat where he's
like I'm a rebel this is what I got left
there's this pitch too is that we all
know Ken loves Barbie I wouldn't go so
far as to say Barbie loves Ken I feel
like that might be a little bit of a
one-way okay the Barbie expert agrees
with me okay good Barbie is her own
person independent
um but what if Ken follows Barbie into
the real world and that's when he's in
the real world he's like I have no money
I have no verses when he's in Barbie
land he is one of people they're in
there you know but but he's willing to
sacrifice everything he has for Barbie
go with her on this journey and she's
like we have to figure out what the real
world is or whatever learn the life the
lesson I wouldn't be surprised if
they're not actually together and when I
say that it's because we know that a lot
of these people like Issa Rae was Cassie
has Barbie and so is Simi lose so it's
like they're all paired off and I think
in this universe they have to be paired
off so when they come to out of the
world they're going to be like we don't
have to be together
IMDb for this movie is still like uh you
know Margot Robbie's Barbie Ryan
Gosling's Ken and then no one else has
like their character listings like
random actors are like businessman
secretary
the last pitch I want to do but you want
to say something about Barbie no go
please go ahead okay Mattel yeah which
owns Barbie right also owns Masters of
the Universe He-Man wouldn't it be sweet
if at the end of this incredibly
stylistic and cool movie they somehow
tease there's another Universe where
there's like an actor that's cast as
He-Man and he's like
doing a Masters of the Universe Live I'm
sitting here doing Polly Pocket I'm
saying scrap that and do whatever uh
Greta is the new feige I want to see
like the big purple sword and like the
fake you know Mattel like toys of Castle
Grayskull
Cinematic Universe
we're so excited we already you know
we're doing break room Barbie watch over
here John Doe we don't have a specific
graphic for that right we just
this movie is coming out next summer
July same weekend as uh Oppenheimer very
similar tone uh Nolan's gonna move
we are eagerly anticipating both films
but especially Barbie here on the break
room uh this is only the beginning of
break room Barbie watching this is a
teaser this is not a full trailer
imagine what we're gonna do when we get
the actual trailer just in 30 minutes on
a minute that's what we just did
um Jessica Jessica and Brandon's uh
brains will melt they'll never be the
same uh and it'll be the best episode of
the break room that'll ever happen
um but uh we're super excited for that
again keep coming back for more Barbie
content but now we want to move on and
cover the other headlines of the day
and delicious all right so in the
history of me doing the break room I
have never once asked for a headline
I've never once been like this is for me
and today I asked because the holiday
reporter is saying that diamond Glover
will be producing and starring in a
movie set in the Sony Spider-Man
universe based on a villain known as
Hypno Hustler
written by Eddie Murphy's son miles
Murphy and I gotta say the reason I'm so
excited for this the reason I'm having
trouble sitting because of the reason
behind this is insane is because Donald
Glover playing Hypno Hustler giving us
the opportunity for all sorts of
incredible Redbone era Childish Gambino
tracks but if you look at the history of
Donald Glover noted Spider-Man fan
Spider-Man fans the level of wearing a
Spider-Man shirt on an episode of
community that episode of community
spawned an entire Donald 4 Spider-Man
campaign yeah be down for Spider-Man
campaign became one of the first viral
campaigns in the history of the internet
because Donald Glover's so ahead of the
internet he made an album nine years ago
last week called because of the internet
which changed everything we should
listen to It's very prophetic but now
today
and you read the script alongside it
it's like Dark Side of the Moon watching
Wizard of Oz but Donald Glover Donald
for Spider-Man turned into a part of the
inspiration from Miles Morales Brian
Michael bennis's credited many times
Donald Glover for being part of the
inspiration for that years later
Spider-Man homecoming he is cast as
Aaron Davis Miles his own Uncle so
Donald now effectively plays his own
Uncle between fiction and non-fiction
blurring the worlds of fiction and
fiction by way of the internet which is
something he prophesied in because the
internet he also voiced miles he also
voicemails him in the first uh Cartoon
that's right so then a year later and
into the spider-verse the animated take
on Miles Morales the character inspired
in part by nudle Glover he then is on
the screen when you first meet the
animated Aaron Davis in the exact frame
from community that inspired the
characters on screen that his uncle
itself is watching and he also played
his uncle and now two years later we
have him in the Spider-Man universe as
Hypno Hustler will he also be Aaron
Davis maybe will he get to have those
climbers to be Prowler maybe but we do
know Hypno Hustler's coming is this Sony
or is Marvel this is Sony this is a
feature real quick is it feature film I
haven't made it that way
I just gave you so many years of
excitement
and real quick we almost the only things
we know are kind of what was in that
that headline Hypno Hustler of course
one of everybody's top five oh yeah
Spider-Man villains uh if you're
unfamiliar he was a George clinton-esque
kind of a musician yeah who would
hypnotize the audience with his
instruments and then Rob them uh it was
a villain a very obscure very
interesting that's what Nickelback did
uh
this kind of follows on the heels of I
feel like the most similar news was Bad
Bunny yeah cast is El muerto again
another very obscure Spider-Man villain
uh but kind of giving these you know
projects this is many degrees lower than
morbius many degrees lower than craving
the hunter yeah or silk even right like
but giving these projects to kind of
known talents like Donald Glover over or
bed money or whatever and just seeing
what they can make from it right um I
think the opportunity for a musical is
like I'm like what a revenue sounds like
would be incredible in a movie like what
that feel of that album is and then
turning that into a Donald Glover joint
where he gets to be like a mix of
Childish Gambino and Donald Glover and
he loves Spider-Man like the scene in
Spider-Man homecoming he literally is
playing like I said the uncle but he's
also webbed to a car and the license
plate of that car is the first
appearance of the character that he
inspired like right he is so in this
universe and you know you know what
sucks this Hypno Hustler movie won't
have Spider-Man in it so it's like what
what
yeah I think he's gonna do the this is
America dance
and I would watch it oh
this like you have no Hustler movie is
basically like lemonade it's just like a
long musical like Anthology thing
47 minutes on Amazon yeah and and you
know this is so early it's kind of wild
that that they're even announcing this
it's not a director attached there's not
a date attached
um there's also Donald Glover has a bit
of a recent history of being a touch of
projects that maybe never happen like
what this is my Barbie Mr Mrs Smith I
don't know if that's okay Waller Bridge
years ago he was also attached to a
Deadpool Animated Series yeah what
happened with that it was like the legal
issue but yeah but he was still attached
he'd written one to the point where he
actually wrote an eight page script that
was leaked from Deadpool but if you read
it it's actually all of that day's news
stories to prove that he was like guys I
could have done this in my sleep and it
was some of the best Deadpool writing
I've ever read yeah especially if he's
like producing something he'll try to
Usher it out especially now that Atlanta
is like done sure he has a lot more free
time yeah can't wait to see his ass he
beats again so like I imagine they'd
want he'd want to make something that
his kids can watch so like a lot of
parents when they had a
I am saying this
as a Donald Glover
those Rolling Stones article was insane
he scares me
the people of that high of like a really
good artist always scare the crap out of
me he is he's a really good artist he's
like a triple threat he's a writer
comedian uh a beautiful actor beautiful
musician
yeah
um and uh served one of my all-time top
tens uh Magic Mike XXL uh okay
um speaking of trilogies that will pay
off Magic Mike uh okay uh moving on to
other headlines and hopefully again
hopefully we get more news about this
this is something that does you know
move into development fast tracked I'm
sure Sony would love that we get it 2024
2025 who knows who knows
um who knows back to the other movie
coming out the same weekend is Barbie
Oppenheimer from Christopher Nolan uh we
got a new trailer for that kind of the
first trailer we've seen teaser footage
and other weird little things but the
first trailer for that is playing in
some theaters ahead of Avatar wave water
which of course comes out today yeah uh
or or yesterday depending on where you
were in the world
um so hopefully that also gets released
online soon and we can all enjoy that in
the nicest way possible do you know how
pissed I'd be to go see the way of water
and not see the Oppenheimer trailer I'd
be so mad or what if you got to see the
Barbie trailer
I'm foreign
I may or may not have been at the movies
right before this launching a movie but
I may or may not have checked every
theater that was fine I went to three
different amateur showings I couldn't
find it are you serious devotion which I
enjoyed okay well what about this
trailer
they were showing it 15 minutes apart so
I like learned for 45 minutes like a
creeper it didn't work out where are we
gonna go see it I wonder too if the if
if this trailer yeah if the trailer is
going to be in front of like non-3d
versions of Avatar because I know for 3D
versions of Avatar they'll try to put
some 3D trailers and I'm like there's an
Ant-Man 3D trailer floating around and
then Super Mario Brothers 3D floating
around and the Little Mermaid teaser
I've seen that in three years so that's
you know wild out there movies
yeah throw in the chat if you've been at
an avatar screening and been able to see
the Oppenheimer trailer um it's also the
first time in years I think that there
hasn't been a release before or
simultaneously with the theater like
just put them online let us see them
like that Nolan loves to do that yeah I
feel like that you did that with tenet
right
um he's trying to shame us to go to the
cinema yeah and he's probably right
there you go yeah
okay I'm gonna see my trailer on your
laptop screen nobody's watching the
iPhone exactly exactly let's remember
when Tom Cruise was like the movies are
back all right
but then he showed that clip of him on
the the plane and he's like they're not
on their back now they're back he was
worried about his movie
um yeah so anyways we're excited about
that again a little pissed that it has
to come out the exact same weekend as
Barbie spread those guys out a little
bit
and then you go into the other and get
happy which is which
um depending on your feelings on nuclear
bombs
um I I do think there's a line in Barbie
where she says I have become death
that spank Sarah through strap um uh
another news so you know we've been
talking Henry Cavill and the future and
or not future of his Superman
um this week as it's kind of been
confirmed he will not be appearing again
as Superman including and stuff he's
already shot that they will be cutting
out a future DC movies
um but hey we're not worried about Mr
Campbell he's got he's already got a big
project lined up he is going to be
starring in presumably and producing a
war hammer 40 000
um Series on Amazon they got the the
rights it's gonna be a film and a series
film in a series thank you
um now Warhammer 40 000 if you're not
familiar and it is pronounced 40 000.
I've never I think it would speak the
word no I think it's 4 Hammer 40k yeah
but I'm already said 40K I just say
Warriors
this is so nerdy I think there is a
previous version of this world and some
sort of Miniatures game and then they
came out with Warhammer 40K and then
that became like the thing kind of like
Starcraft and so like when Super
Nintendo came out a lot of people didn't
remember Nintendo be like generationally
yeah
the story is Warhammer yeah it was fun
by a company uh created it that had been
um creating uh metallic figurines for
Dungeons and Dragons in the 80s and then
they created their own game because they
were like hey people love these
figurines let's build a game around
these figurines thus was Warhammer now
um Henry Cavill noted fans
uh big old Gaming geek and he's like
released videos of himself painting the
figurines and stuff like that like he's
a very outspoken gamer in general but
specifically about this so cool yeah I
mean Tommy's Tommy's released some
videos of him painting figurines but we
can't show this oh it's not though
[Music]
um in other news Marvel news Peyton Reed
director of both or all three Ant-Man
movies yeah uh gave an interview to
Entertainment Weekly and uh he had some
interesting quotes there that have got
us jazzed we were already jazzed about
quantumania of course but uh this kind
of goes in line with what we've been
talking about that trailer for
quantumania is like so much more epic
than the previous two Ant-Man movies and
some of his quotes kind of aligned with
that he said for the third one I don't
want to be the palette cleanser anymore
I want to be the big Avengers sweet I'll
give it to him he's earned it yeah yeah
even the placement of Ant-Man and the
WASP yes was like between two big movies
it was a post-credits scene was like
everything people talked about not the
movie yeah it's funny it's very yeah
maybe like this movie has the
opportunity to like reshape you know say
it yeah
people are definitely gonna you know
post those images on like superhero
Instagram it's like who had the best
Trilogy Captain America Iron Man
Spider-Man and man like people are gonna
start including him in the conversation
so yeah
um
yes we hope this movie is huge and
awesome um
you wanna
you went a little bit about the
character Bill Murray is playing in this
film Bill Murray who's had like one
second of footage in the trailer and
like not a lot else now some of that
might be for some ice cream reasons uh
but Murray hasn't had the best year uh
publicity wise but um a couple decades
oh yeah yeah
that's right yeah some of the recent
publicity
Ghostbusters holds up
but as a person I don't know so I can't
vouch uh but um uh the kirchi plays is a
character from Janet van dyne's past I
believe we've we've heard that quote
before
um but he goes on to say as we know from
great stories you can put the past
behind you but the past will always find
a way to show up again Bill's character
represents that in this movie
interesting so he's definitely sleeping
with it I think that's the thing that
she doesn't want to reach out for right
when in the trailer of the like you're
sending a signal to the quantum realm my
ex is down there I think it's Bill
Murray maybe he leads the quantum like
the people like it seems to be like a
village of sorts like maybe he's their
leader and yeah I love that idea that
it's not King that brings them
or if even if like what if she has a bit
of a dark past some of her time in the
quantum realm yeah what if she was doing
some like Heart of Darkness type stuff
and slaughtering villagers and whatever
and he's like you know the leader of the
people that she was wiping out or
something like that you know jeez
somebody's gonna go see Oppenheimer
uh maybe Bill Murray's just playing Bill
Murray and Janet van dyne's like we
can't go we Bill Murray's in there I
don't want to go in there he's
inappropriate I don't want to go
the paint goes well Ghostbusters to the
whole time
they were like get out of here hey shut
up you're old
um
real quick we have one of this is our
last show of the year I don't know if I
already said that since we've been live
our very last show of 2022 that our
launch here for the break room
um uh and we have what might be
the best mandatory fun of the entire
year coming up real quick I just before
we get to that we want to plug new
rockstarsmerch.com uh hey maybe you're
looking for a last minute holiday gift
maybe you want to treat yourself yeah uh
we've got some really fun there's some
great shirts we got the uh wakanda
forever latest Obsession shirt is still
available there's limited edition of
that we got enamel pins some really fun
sticker sets that we've been showing off
on the show this week head over to
newrexmerch.com grab yourself something
or something for a friend uh it's a
great way to support the channel and
support the break room uh but now
without further ado
for the final time in 2022. let's hit
that graphic yeah
[Music]
you only get the graphic ones just
there it is there you go okay
folks 2022 has been a great idea for
Content I think about it it's been a
great year for content and while we hate
to see it leave we love to watch it go
so now is the perfect time to play a
little game we like to call
America's favorite game
okay here's how it's gonna work team I'm
gonna show you a butt and you will have
to tell me the character that that butt
belongs to oh my God now the first the
first few are all gonna be from Marvel
projects from this year everyone is from
our project this year okay okay the
first few are gonna be offer marble
products these are series special
presentations movies whatever but some
of the later ones will be from other
content in 2020 but everything's from
this year everything will be from this
year and real quick audience play along
feel free we we currently have the chat
obscure yeah it can't impact the actual
game but feel free to play it amongst
everyone's drawings that's all yeah
already drawing by splitting cheeks
I will show you a butt you write down
who it is okay and then you'll have to
reveal your butt and we will reveal the
correct answer uh that's a good place
John show us our first book okay
okay okay there's your first one okay
that is it that is zoomed in but now
this is a 2022 Marvel butt a 2022 Marvel
box no one look at my right oh
oh man that is hard not much time left
on the clock 22 marvel three seconds
okay
not feeling great all right Zach will
begin with you okay I don't feel great
about this one it was a default one I
feel like it's a very safe guess okay I
went water he's in everything that's a
good I like bronze I said Everett Ross
but also white blood white yes I went
Chinese but I'm going win-woo because
that fabric
toys they put out and I was like
also I went green butt I went home
show us the butt whose butt is that
very white now I need you to guess that
but oh my God that butt is weird
I'm like cycling through all the Marvel
projects in 2022. almost like he's
wearing denim
give me the butt
oh okay but it's gone the next butt will
be right down here you got three seconds
I'm pretty excited about this one that's
delicious I think I got it a world
famous delicious denim but okay we'll
start with koi who do you got going a
falcon chairs
it's Kevin Bacon
that was a very skinny bite so who was
who was closest
all right very close with the white bike
normal human Bucky I'm gonna need you to
pull up the third punch third butt okay
it's my favorite thing I've done all
year okay
this is not from a Marvel project okay
okay uh this is my natural butt nothing
is covering you're seeing a real butt
there that's skin that's skin butt oh
crap oh I see this is not a Marvel
project something oh okay
oh it's someone's butt this is outside
of marble maybe that window gives you a
clue don't don't be is that Wednesday
I'm gonna go
a prominent butt this year vekna's bunch
because you know he's not wearing any
clothes interesting interesting so I'm
going to say something you got an answer
yeah I did White Lotus Nicola oh
yeah I didn't watch it I don't know any
characters names but I'm going game
John show us the butt please
I know that okay again this is not
Marvel this is outside of Marvel you
don't say it's got the vicious six
very popular movie this year this is
from a movie
immediately know it award winning Coy
probably saw it you saw more because
sometimes he definitely saw this I was
at this Premiere you were at this
Premiere yeah okay
this is Gru from the minions right
immediately Romanians minions
I know I'm wrong but this is a Disney
plus original Diary of a Wimpy Kid rules
we got any more butts back there
this is a Marvel project
this is a Marvel project what's up there
okay is that Dracula this is a bent over
butt right here bent over this is marble
this year this was Marvel this year
difficult to find a bud in this one it's
not what Marvel does a good job with not
doing butt coverage yeah good good for
them this is this year but this is this
year okay
no wait wait give me a second give me a
second I feel okay about this I feel
good about this one 96. I'm sorry I'm
just typing I'm just writing okay Cory
why don't we start with you the
character I believe is Elsa Bloodstone
the movie I believe is a werewolf by
night okay oh yeah I specifically said
Jack and Robin so if you said Bloodstone
you said Elsa Bloodstone black panther I
also went Jack Russell and werewolf by
night John show us the butt it's
actually Elsa
[Laughter]
okay check out this button what this is
from Marvel or no more I will say it's
from Marvel I will say it's from Marvel
you would say oh I think I
I will say this this falls under the
purview of Marvel give me one second I'm
trying to remember you have one second
give me the second I have to get out of
here
hard to see
easy to remember
who had this delicious butt it's hard to
make it out in this outfit
oh crap this isn't right
I'll give you five seconds
um
three two one we'll start with you Zach
what do you got okay uh I oh I I wrote
the actor not the character I'm saying
that's cragland and Guardians of the
Galaxy holiday special okay I said Todd
Todd oh that's a good guess She-Hulk
okay yep John show us the butt
that's a morbius butt baby
the amount of times
to that movie to find a button
John let's pull another boat let's pull
up another button John give me another
button
S
I mean this should be instantaneous all
right let's let's do these answers folks
come on everyone's right now that's
white butt that's B white butt Thor love
and Boots
15 more butts
okay
this is not a Marvel property I will
tell you about it but popular very
popular
I don't think they wear this in Star
Wars uh and or would have some jeans
break out of jail put on some denims
yeah yeah we call this space denim I
think I know it this is I feel pretty
confident I'm almost Thor confident I
think Zach is right
that's honest as soon as I looked at
this I was like oh that's a good guess
all right we'll start with you I do
believe that is the butt of a Maverick
all right I went white people project
White Lotus I said white people project
white loaded I also went on cruises John
show us that if it's not Tom Cruise's
account
all right one more foreign
it feels like it's zooming in is it I
mean it's it's always moving I'm not
it's it's following me around the room
yeah yeah depending if you cross your
eyes it's actually three-dimensional oh
yeah that's right I'd like to thank our
team of researchers me to come through
hours yeah don't don't check Brandon's
search history and if you're a director
out there make sure you get butt
coverage in these movies no make my job
a little easier If This Were the 90s it
would be so easy to do Zach will start
with the acting is in the face I think
that was mantis from guardians
says Hector do you have El Nino
well folks it's been a great year you
can make an argument that butt might
have won 2022 yeah
they could erase the front but they
couldn't erase the background
I wanted to pull a stone of Nakia in
that movie oh I didn't know
yeah that would have got us
well clay you are the biggest perv on
the panel
six and a half what did I get you got a
Hector had three butts Zach had three
butts just had two bucks and I love bugs
uh Stephanie Horton saying happy
holidays gonna miss you I'll see you in
2023 we'll see you then uh Elena 3jb
thank you for making my year can't to
see can't wait to see what 2023 holds
it's mostly Barbie don't worry about
that uh Aaron storm hope you all have a
wonderful holiday big Tiki sandbox
congrats on a great break room here
proud of you guys we're proud of you
thank you Deanna Chanel thanks for the
huge Super Chat thanks so much swoop
John B Killa Heroes feature Heroes
reforged baby that's me
uh Anthony Virgil love the break room
don't know what I'm gonna do without you
for the next few weeks hold it down
annoy your family members Point things
out to them so uh re-watch our episodes
yeah and turn off their motion smoothing
on their TV yeah no yes if you're with
your parents this weekend turn off their
emotions don't even bother explaining it
they won't get it just do it for them
just turn it off thank you nerdy by
Nature happy holidays to you thank you
haven't seen you in a minute Dad thanks
so much for the super chats uh Jessica's
got that shade for Shoney
thank you so much yeah and thank you to
everybody in the chat and everybody
that's watching and has watched Us in
2022 and everybody that helped us bring
the show uh to you this year we've got
some really big plans like this was kind
of like a a fun experiment today doing
the the real time uh live breakdown we
might have some other fun formats we
might mix in next year's days like the
first week oh you gotta Show episode
will only be be about me yeah uh we had
Comic-Con this year we'll have Jessica
Khan uh next year Jessica he's the
better
um yeah be sure to check out if you
haven't already seen our multiple uh
into this spider-verse breakdowns that
are up on the channel right now check
those out also since we don't see you
before then get jazzed for January uh uh
just for January uh The Last of Us
coming out on HBO we're gonna be
covering that hopefully we get some more
great Marvel and Star Wars trailers when
are they gonna announce the premiere
date for secret evasion hopefully soon
we know that uh swansomania is coming
out in February 17th and we know we know
in season three early 2023 I think
division spring as the push to
quantumania they'll probably announce
because they'll want a ride that
momentum Marvel's good at doing like one
two punches I think they'll make that
part put out a trailer give us a release
date give us a release date and maybe
another trailer wouldn't be bad
um but uh most of all thank you all so
much for being a part of our of our
weird little family here in New
rockstars uh we've got to put Jessica to
bed
she was up too late we started your
Barbie I mean I was in the slashes
yelling Barbies yeah okay boy absolutely
thank you nikoi and Hector for being
here uh anybody have a great holidays
see you next year
can we just see the other butts
the other four
[Music]